[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
there is a stranger who coming to this
village from the sea it was in the
winter when people are hungry and fish
comes on the king guys I was last night
took I believe that an enemy is coming
and far away
I'm looking for warriors this stranger
others like him
[Music]
I'm building an alliance to defend on
it's very important I through this man
[Music]
Barry Allen this way said that like it
explains whether the total strangers
sitting in the dark in my second
favorite chair
he said he'll fight with us more more or
more less
[Music]
probably more luck
he said now is it enough look man I
don't know who you are but whoever
you're looking for you're fat stop feels
like an oversimplification I'm putting
together special ability I believe and I
think you're coming
stop right there come in you are just
like that
yeah
I need friends
[Applause]
I heard about you didn't think you were
real
I'm realize useful
Arthur curry here you can talk to fish
[Music]
you
you